hey guys so as promised I want to do
more anime reviews on my channel because
I'm a huge fan of anime I love it and I
think it's an art form that doesn't get
the respect it deserves
it's influenced so much entertainment
around the world and so many people
aren't aware of how great some of these
animes can be and what I've been
promising is to do a review of kids on
the slope kids on the slope is directed
by Shinichiro Watanabe who also directed
Cowboy Bebop samurai Champloo and a
little bit of space dandy which is a
newer show I haven't had a chance to
watch it but I actually do have season
one and I will watch that eventually I'm
pointing over there because that's where
my and my blu-rays are so if you're like
why is he pointing over there that's
because they're through there over there
this enemy takes place during the summer
of 1966 and Karuna Shima is a student
who's new at this school he's not really
fitting in and he has an intense love of
jazz music and performing it on the
piano not a lot of other people around
him are really into it yet because
everyone at the time is really into the
Beatles and rock and roll music and when
he meets Sentaro this kind of badass kid
who's a punk but he is totally
incredible on the drums as well as RIT
Zuko who's a girl whose father owns a
music store they team up to create a
little tiny band an underground band
literally underground that go
underground in the basement of this
store and they create this small jazz
band and the music they create slowly
starts to spread through their school
and their popularity Rises but it's
really more about their relationships
their friendship their budding
adolescence and the fact that they are
learning more about themselves while
also learning how to be better musicians
I love this show
I thought it was a very original show in
fact I saw it before whiplash and it's
funny because they're both pieces of
entertainment that are about young
people who have a serious love for jazz
music who are trying to show the world
their creativity and the way they took
two things which was learning about
music being better at music and learning
about life and being better at life and
trying to combine those two into one
world through the eyes of kids who
really don't know that much about the
world and the fact that I'm saying all
of these things about what someone might
look at and go this is a cartoon it's
probably for kids is amazing I mean this
is a really good show it's really well
directed it has beautiful animation
sheera watanabe and his animators have
cut no corners when it comes to the
animation it's bright it's crisp it's
very fluid and everyone really moves a
lot and that's something to say about
anime because sometimes anime animators
in Japan get a little bit lazy they
don't let their characters move that
much the models are a little bit weak
they look a little bit robotic sometimes
sometimes it's just like the mouth going
up and down and maybe the eyes will
blink every once in a while but there
isn't that much animation given to the
way the humans are moving like really
natural things like the wind going
through a character's hair or shadows
passing along someone's face all of
these things are animated in this show
and everything looks painstaking and
that's one of the things I loved about
it was not just the music and the
characters but how well-done the
animation was and since there is that
underdog aspect to the show where you
have characters who aren't that
well-known who are kind of looked down
upon
send Taro's like the punk kid who gets
in fights all the time and no one really
wants to talk to him because they're all
scared of him and of course our main
character has just moved there so these
are new things for him as well
and ritsuka was a very reserved girl who
loves singing she loves music but she
has a really hard time expressing that
part about herself even though her
father owns a music store and so to see
these three characters come together and
the various relationships that come out
of that I thought it was a really
beautiful show and I was watching
episode after episode I watched all 12
episodes in just a couple days and
that's really fast for me because I
usually have a lot of other things I
have to watch too and I adored this show
it blew by really fast as for issues my
only issue is just one there are times
when some of the romance gets a little
melodramatic even for an anime because
if you are an anime fan you guys know as
well as I do that sometimes romance
animes can get a little bit cheesy and
you're like okay this is kind of soap
opera territory here and that's it
besides that kids in the slope is a
beautifully animated anime of this it
has great music
it has great characters and it's really
exciting I'm going to give kids on the
slope and a - so guys I do hope you get
a chance to check this out it is a
really good kind of bridge anime because
it's not like swords and gigantic
breasts and like crazy monsters and
stuff it's just a very simple anime that
I think a lot of people could really
enjoy not that there's anything
along with girls and dinosaurs and big
swords those are all nice things but
guys I am really excited about something
for the past few months I have been
doing a promotion with crunchyroll which
is an online streaming service for anime
and I've been offering my viewers 30
days of that for free at crunchyroll.com
slash Chris Stockman but I've recently
made a deal with them to continue that
throughout the rest of this year I love
crunchyroll these guys are amazing I
love their service they're huge anime
fans they created crunchyroll to
preserve an easy and enjoyable
experience for anime fans because they
are anime fans and they respect it as an
artform and they want to bring as much
of that to us and kids on the slope is
on crunchyroll so if you guys would like
30 days of that service for free
completely free you can go to
crunchyroll.com slash Chris Stockman
through me you guys can have that for
free my gift to you guys if you want to
watch kids on the slope the entire show
is on there have fun I hope you guys
enjoy it and that is something I'm going
to be doing for the rest of the year I'm
really looking forward to continuing to
work with crunchyroll these guys are
fantastic and one things I love about
them is they get a lot of shows that
have aired in Japan within just a few
hours and they already have the English
subtitled versions available for us
which is so awesome and it's all in HD
so if you'd like to watch their show or
any other of their plethora of awesome
shows and entertainment go to
crunchyroll.com slash Chris Stockman
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I really appreciate it and as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck Munoz